how to turn your passion into a business
so I've got an awesome question for one
of my YouTube viewers love you guys
susmita who wrote in the say I've only
watched through of your videos including
this one and I Love You Man
in a completely non homosexual way I
completed my undergraduate degree last
year and I very recently discovered my
passion for Latin dancing and I can't
seem to get enough of it I feel like
dancing is all I want to do right now
but I can't see any way that I can turn
this passion to something lucrative
anytime in the near future but I know
that if I stop dancing now for the sake
of academic or professional development
it would drill a hole through my heart
and I will regret it forever keep making
these videos very inspirational Susmita
I love a man I'm feeling the passion and
and as somebody who's gotten deep into
the salsa world I can definitely relate
to what you're going through I want to
share a couple stories the first is of
Sharon she's the founder of Toronto
dance salsa it's a company that I've
invested in and when she was getting
into salsa she was at the Marriott hotel
chain and she was she's a go-getter
she's she's she was rising up through
the ranks she got four promotions in
four years and was on the fast track to
success and one day she walked into a
salsa club named babalu here in in
Toronto and city and she just fell in
love with it she had no dancing
background she had two left feet she
Sarcos stepping on people but there was
something about the vibe the music the
energy the people she wanted to keep
going and so it started off as hey this
is fun thing we can go let's go check it
out and it became an obsession she
started going out every night she
started now sleeping four or five hours
a night because she had to wake up early
to go to her job at the Mary but she was
she was ugly
the last night before going salsa
dancing and it was taking a toll on her
but but she got through because she
loved the day insane so much and because
of that passion and led to her becoming
better right joint she went out every
night she sucked at the start she was
the worst of her friends she picked up
so slowly but because she kept at it she
got better and that
and better and eventually she joined a
performance team and she got better
through the performance team then she
started teaching a few classes with the
school that offered the performance
class and I don't know if she got paid
if she did it wasn't very much for
teaching those classes still nowhere
near compared to what she was making at
the Marion then from there competing
school well that was in ballroom wanted
to launch a salsa division and they
recruited her to go and join and she
started teaching classes there and they
wanted her to jump on and become
full-time teaching salsa and that was a
difficult decision for her because here
she was on the fast track to success
making really good money at the Marion
and she felt like if I go and do this
teaching salsa thing I'm gonna make
twenty twenty-five thousand dollars a
year so I have a white balance that she
went through the same thing you're going
through right now because she felt like
it would roll up drill a hole in her
heart and she would live with regret if
she didn't take that job didn't take
that opportunity so she quit her job at
the Marriott went to go do the salsa
thing and turned into a full-time career
and it turned out well for her right now
she's making way more money than she
ever was making at the Marriott she
turned that opportunity into eventually
breaking away from the school having her
own school launching it up to being one
of the biggest Latin dancing schools in
North America and it all came because
she started from trusting her passion
right wouldn't you were following your
passion you don't know how it's gonna
work out and that's the big problem like
you're looking at this saying I love
dancing I love Latin dancing but I don't
know how it's gonna work out and a lot
of people did let that hold them back
from starting because you don't know how
it's gonna work out you don't see the
end goal that prevents you from starting
where a lot of times with this the
staircase appears as you take each step
you don't know what that last step looks
like but you'll get there because as you
take a step the next step becomes
visible and the next step becomes
visible and so on this is the difference
between making decisions with your heart
I'm making it with your head the biggest
decisions in life
you have to make with your heart and
trust that it's going to work out and it
will work out if you love dancing your
everything you have into it it may be
you become a DJ or you become a teacher
or you become you start doing DVDs or
you start our website whatever it is
there's so many opportunities and you
can't figure that all out right now but
by following your passion and listen to
your heart it will work out let me share
my example my story with you I first
went to salsa dancing on a date and then
I took up another class at the same time
to learn more moves her can impress the
girl that I was on the date with and I
just fell in love with it you know I
didn't know salsa growing up I didn't
know the music I didn't I didn't
understand the counts I don't speak
Spanish I'm tall which counted against
me because my steps were too big at the
start and so if I was looking at it from
a business opportunity right I thought
you just sold my company and now here's
my chance to launch a new company a
business opportunity you're gonna plan
it out here's what I'm gonna do it
wouldn't make any sense
salsa didn't make any sense at all as an
opportunity for me to get involved with
because I didn't have any of the track
record or experience or history or music
musicality nothing I sucked but I loved
it and I didn't worry so much about it
making it into a business right now I
just followed that love that eventually
led me to meet Sharon get connected
Toronto dance salsa I'm now an investor
in the school i DJ most of the events at
the school I've got a whole bunch of
YouTube videos on dance and you can find
online I teach one of the classes the
highest level class level six at the
school so I'm actively involved in it
because I love it like I'm still out
dancing 20 25 hours a week because it it
fills me up here I love the people I
love the community I love the music I
love the dancing if I didn't have it I
would feel like somebody drilled a hole
through my heart still like this is
maybe I don't know ten years ten years
since it's been a long time and so I
would never have figured out from
walking in that first day that this is
how I would make a career out of salsa
cher would never figure it out walking
into that first club how she would ever
make money out of salsa but we both
continued on and you have to continue
one because you
what you're doing always listen to your
heart and those big decisions and trust
that the staircase will appear as you
start climbing believe those you're
watching you like the video you can
subscribe to the channel see more just
like it thank you so much I'll see you
soon if you want some believe in your
inbox every week to keep you motivated
check out the link below to join my
newsletter